Now that we've covered how our AI can sense the world around them, we can discuss how
we can tailor the environment to give them objects to interact with.
This is a new system added in Unreal Engine 5 called the smart object system.
So what are smart objects?
As the name suggests, they're objects placed in the world that both AI agents
and players can interact with.
These objects contain all of the necessary information to handle the interaction logic
for that object.
Smart objects are part of a global database of smart objects and they use partitioning logic.
This means that they can be queried at runtime using things such as location as an example.
One of the key advantages of this system is that it also uses a reservation system.
This means that other AI agents or players can be aware of in-use smart objects near them.
This prevents multiple AI agents selecting the same object at the same time.
Smart objects have their own subsystem that keeps track of all of the smart objects in your level.
This subsystem is created automatically in the level when the smart object plugin is enabled.
It's worth noting that only one smart object subsystem can exist at any one time.
However, it is worth noting that in multiplayer games, the smart object subsystem is only
instantiated on the server or authority machine.
As we can see in the picture at the bottom of this slide, the smart object subsystem
is used to query for and return smart objects.
It's essentially a cache for our AI to bounce off of.
The smart object collection contains a list of all smart object components associated
within the level.
The collection holds all shared configurations and is used to create all runtime instances
of smart objects to enable efficient, large world simulation outside of loaded areas.
And again, there is only one smart object collection per level.
So now we know what smart objects are and how the backend system works, but how do
we go about creating a smart object of our own?
Well that's where the smart object component comes in.
Smart object components can be added to any actor, thus converting them to a smart
object, and these will be picked up in the smart object subsystem.
This component sets up and stores the configuration of a given smart object template.
This component still adheres to the world partitioning logic, so an actor holding this
component can still be loaded and unloaded, whether using the world partitioning or level
streaming systems.
If the actor holding this component is spawned at runtime, then it will not remain in memory
once it has been unloaded.
A smart object definition is a data structure that contains immutable data that is shared
between multiple instances of a smart object.
This definition stores filtering information such as user-required tags, descriptive tags
and the default set of behaviors to execute on interaction.
It also exposes out one or more available slots that can be used by either AI agents
or players.
Each of these slots contain the following.
Firstly we have the location and rotation of the slot relative to the parent anchor,
both of which are baked in from editor placement.
They also allow us to define a specific behavior per slot that can override the default
set of behaviors for this object.
They also allow us to define a set of gameplay tags, user tags and runtime tags.
Lastly we come to smart object behavior definitions.
These definitions contain the data needed by an AI agent or player for a given interaction.
Some common behavior examples are gameplay behaviors.
These are used by a pawn or actor to perform their behaviors.
There's player behaviors and this behavior is specifically built for player characters
that can use smart objects.
Or you could use the mass entity behaviors, which is a behavior that makes use of the
smart object behavior definition to configure a smart object to be used by mass entities
rather than usual gameplay behavior actor pawn architectures.
Finally it's worth noting that gameplay behaviors can be implemented directly in Blueprint.